let's bring in reggie miller who joins
us from the bubble how long did it take
you
to pronounce yana sadet kumpo
oh wow i don't know i still have it down
and it's bo not po people don't
understand that
that it's beau not poe thank you rich
reg will be on the call mavs sons at 4
eastern blazers nets at 9 eastern on tnt
so uh double duty here should we have
bubble awards
i think it's fun i mean we're in unique
times this is a different situation
and certainly uh yeah i
i think uh just to highlight again some
teams and some players have played
a little bit harder than others some are
still getting going but it's
it's fun it's catchy okay where would
you
showcase your bubble award if i came
into your house
and you had won a bubble award reg
i would say oh come here i would have
opened up my my
bottom sock drawer okay pulled it out
and like hey
i was mvp of the bubble you know back in
20 20.
i think we should just call it uh potb
player of the bubble
um is it well who's your pick
damian lillard tj warren for a little
while there was the jordan of the bubble
so
who is the mvp are you going with uh
bubble mvp
yeah right now yeah i i probably would
go
damian miller has been fantastic
incredible numbers
what he's doing to push them probably to
that a spot
i have to go with devin booker i mean
look
as great as uh you know 7-0 for the
phoenix suns
no one expected them to be on this run
and in contention
possibly they still can get that a spot
but i still think they can get that nice
spot
and have those playing games i think
it's
you can't go wrong between lillard and
booker i give this
very slight very slight edge to devin
booker
just because right now they are the only
undefeated team
uh in the bubble and they have a shot of
actually
you know playing for those playing games
in the western conference
and then we have suns and blazers on
saturday
yeah if it is those two phoenix excuse
me
uh memphis is still in play and san
antonio spurs
are still unemployed so it's gonna come
down to tonight's games
three of those teams are on our network
san antonio
obviously phoenix we mentioned in
portland portland
of brooklyn in the nightcap the greek
freak gets suspended for one game for
headbutting mo
wagner what did you make of that
well it's convenient that he gets one
game he wasn't going to play tonight's
game anyway
okay if the playoffs started tomorrow is
the greek freak suspended for that first
game yeah i still think he was
i just thought maybe they were going to
give him two games and then he would
have been
missed game one of the first round but
it's a one-game suspension
i get it i've been there i've been
head-butted before
so i understand it waiting but didn't
you head bud
no i was headbutted by john starks
oh i was headbutted by john stark
and i reacted the same way vlogner did
you know you act like you're like
been shot out of the kid oh my god
what has happened to me lordy
oh but yeah it wasn't that hard and
actually
more of his fro got
wagner than anything else
but i thought oh okay so starks is the
one who hit you
he had budded me okay it got thrown out
yes
you should have been a theater major
ucla the way you played
you got to look look at me i'm not the
biggest of guys you've got to be able to
use a little bit of everything
so i wouldn't necessarily as you say
it wasn't flopping theodore i was
acting like acting but it helped you but
i'm how frustrated did people get
players get
because you were flailing a little bit
or acting a little bit and getting calls
uh very frustrated and i think that's
where
the trash talking kind of came in
because once i would get the call
and they're over there griping to the
official and they would come to me like
you know man up and then i would kind of
whisper things back to them and
that's how a lot of these like little
in-game rivalries kind of evolve
is during those type of interactions or
dramatic acting as i call them did
jordan get suspended for
trying to gouge your eyes out no oh yes
he did
oh okay i was suspended one game you're
talking about the big fight we had
i was suspended i don't know if that was
a big fight
you're right it couldn't that was an
under car that wasn't a fight
it could have escalated i got suspended
a game he got suspended i believe
three games over there okay but if you
remember
i got thrown out of that game
he got to continue that game
in market square in indiana wow
that's the power of jordan yeah we're
talking to reggie miller the hall of
famer he's got two games today mavs sons
at four eastern and blazers nets at nine
eastern on
tnt i'm just looking at the numbers here
i try not to be
uh somebody who overreacts but i'm just
looking at the raw numbers with the
lakers
not a good field goal percentage from
two point range
certainly three point range here and you
could be walking right into the portland
trailblazers or phoenix suns here
how much concern do you have with the
lakers now that we're winding down the
regular season and the postseason starts
next week
i will say this if kyle kuzma can play
like he played against the denver
nuggets when he hit the game winner and
he is that
third outlet he is that third presence
on the floor
i wouldn't be so worried but again the
game of basketball it's not a light
switch you can't turn it on and turn it
off
i like to see consistency i like to see
a team having
a rhythm and playing well as they're
building up as they're ramping up
getting ready for the playoffs
we have not seen that from the lakers is
it concerning
yes but at the end of the day you still
have lebron
and you still have anthony davis who by
the way has struggled
as well in this bubble restart so i
would love to see a little bit more
consistency
in terms as you mentioned the numbers of
shooting
but if they come out and if it's against
portland
if it's against phoenix or whoever
memphis san antonio in the first round
and they go 4-1 this will be a mute
point
but if they struggle remember these
teams that they
potentially could be playing every game
has been a playoff game for them
so they're already playing at playoff
level it's not a light switch
if the shooting's not there it could be
a very long series for the lakers yeah
that's what i wondered about let's say
portland gets in
and every game has been a playoff game
for them at some point you may run out
of that energy
that you have or you know can you go on
a run
because you've been playing at playoff
level basketball there
that that would be my big curiosity with
no matter who the lakers face
those teams are coming in scratching and
clawing
yeah you you're wondering if they're
going to run out of gas yeah but i think
for portland they have
i think they've been campaigning
especially uh damian lillard
if you remember before this bubble
restart when they were
questioning uh who were they going to
bring and
were they going to have a shot at making
the playoffs dame says look
if we don't have a shot of making the
playoffs i'm just going to sit on the
sideline and cheer my
my teammates on i think that's why they
formatted
what we're seeing right now and the way
he
is playing i don't see any let down on
his end
the thing that kind of concerns me
though with the portland trailblazers
is the health report and the injury to
cj mccollum
i know he's having a back issue right
now and
he's that other guy that puts so much
pressure offensively on you
if he's not a hundred percent healthy um
i still believe portland could upset the
lakers
but it diminishes their chances if he's
not at 100
give me the other team that you would
say keep an eye on
certain if it's in the west or the east
look there's going to be some
unbelievable first-round match-ups
um we have like rivalry matchups we've
got
boston versus philadelphia uh al horford
versus his old team
we've got jimmy butler versus tj warren
miami versus
indiana how about cp3 getting a chance
to go against
uh james harden and russell westbrook
russ coyne against okc's
a lot of history in these first round
matchups
something that's going to be exciting to
see i mean if there's a team
that possibly could rise up again i'm
putting my chips with
with portland because they're damian
lillard is playing on a different planet
right now
and if guys continue to taunt him in the
bubble
i'm just telling you guys he is not the
one to do this with
a guy that has the ball 90 of the time
with unlimited range and a purple light
you do not trash talk guys like that
that
can put 50 on you anytime they step on
the floor
and he goes back to back though over 50.
that doesn't happen very often in nba
history and these are all big games
i'm also curious you know we saw what
happened with the greek freak we've seen
some trash talking there
we've you know followed what damian
lillard has been saying back and forth
the clippers with what they were doing
with damian lillard
are players starting to go a little stir
crazy there in the bubble wrench
i think so and i think i think it came
out yesterday that
oh oh my goodness we're gonna be able to
bring some family and friends in here
pretty soon because i think they've been
in isolation um it's been
them and 15 of their teammates in
coaching and coaching staff
and management i think so i think
they're going a little stir crazy and i
think that's why they
kind of let up on their restrictions a
little bit being
able allowing you know family members
and close friends if you can
prove that they're a close friend i
think they're going to open up their
restrictions and i think that will kind
of lessen the tension a little bit
but again we're getting ready for
playoffs and usually come playoff times
that's when guys are probably at their
moodiest so
um i don't know i think that maybe
they're going a little stir crazy but
it's fun to watch i'll tell you that do
you think the nba adopts this play-in
scenario
as we move forward when we leave the
bubble i i think if
if there is no vaccine in the near
future
uh i think we can have multiple vocals
next year i think we can have a an east
coast bubble and a west coast
no the play in you know what we're we're
seeing
okay i like it the only disadvantage i
think it is it's for
the number one seed because you don't
know who you can't prepare and you don't
know who you're gonna
play for but if you're the number one
seed do you really care who the eighth
spot you shouldn't be worrying about the
a spot if you're the number one c
i think that's the only disadvantage but
it gives a little bit of a
feel towards like the the march madness
you got to play yourself in it gives
teams an actual shot of competing
if i look at you know people want to
look at this whoever wins
is there an asterisk attached to it and
i said yeah there might be because of
the degree of difficulty is harder than
probably any other year that we've had
in nba history
a bonus asterisk is what you get the
lakers with no home court advantage
let's say they would face
portland rockets clippers
and then let's say the bucks i don't
know if you can find a team
in nba history that has gone through
something like that
and not had home court advantage you
throw that in there as well
that's why i have no problem saying
anybody who wins a title
i'll give you one and a half titles this
whoever wins this championship will have
wanted
all the points that you just mentioned
you're going to be going through all the
tough teams
and i cannot stress this enough because
being in these
uh arenas and with no fans
and these teams manufacturing their own
energy because there's been a tendency
and to me the games have been fantastic
they've been close they've been
competitive
and i'll give all the guys credit
because for the most part they came back
in shape
but they have had to find motivation
in other ways and if you can win this
championship
with everything that's factored in um
you're right it's an asterisk it's an
asterisk on the good side because you
will have
actually had to go out and win it
well it's going to be fun i i don't want
to
have preferential treatment or say i'm
rooting for somebody but if you said the
suns and the blazers
were going to be playing against one
another i would be
or a plan oh my goodness devin booker
versus damian lillard that alone that's
a headliner for that playing game
remember whoever is eight only has to
win one game
the ninth place team has to win two
games to get that a spot
so i love it it would be fantastic i'm
not rooting for anyone
as well but right now my two
bubbled mvps are damian lillard and
devin booker
let them settle it in a play-in game and
right now they've set themselves up
for that to happen and i'm glad that
we've been able to see
some of these players that we wouldn't
normally see and devin booker is front
and center because
he's one of the great shooters in the
nba you know he's he's one of the top
five you know form his beautiful looking
shot there
i don't know how good that team is uh
you know deandre ayton and
i don't know i don't know if that's a
full team but it is an exciting team to
watch because of him and the same with
portland
they have the ingredients to be a
formidable team
i just don't know if they're going to be
able to put it all together in time to
do that so
it should be a lot of fun and i'm glad
you know tj warren some of these other
players you wouldn't normally see
are uh are playing uh you know some good
basketball and we're getting the
opportunity to witness that
it's great to talk to you have fun uh
this afternoon and tonight
i i appreciate it and i'm a little upset
i'm with you
i i woke up grumpy the last couple days
we uh we got robbed yeah we got robbed i
consider myself the fifth danette
and um look i give you a lot of credit
your reaction was great
but trust me if i would have been with
you guys in front of that camera i would
be like this is
boom
where's our sports emmy you're lucky
you're lucky i wasn't with you guys
that would pretty much guarantee we
wouldn't have a shot at next year
maybe that's why they haven't given it
to us yes
but you know what if we had won you
would have gotten a sports emmy
well i would have gotten i would have
made sure that you got a sports emmy
because your family always honored to be
in your guys's presence again i always
tell people they always ask
you know house theodore and howard the
danettes i'm like i am a fifth dan head
i'm an adopted child i'm part of the
family
thank you reg appreciate it guys love
you that's uh reggie aloysius miller
junior iii he's got a doubleheader today